and welcome to the weekend everyone I'm
Anthony Mason along with Dana Jacobson
and we begin this morning with
developments in the high-stakes
relationship between the u.s. and North
Korea the historic nuclear arms summit
between President Trump and North Korean
leader Kim jong-un is back on the two
leaders will meet June 12th in Singapore
the original date and location for the
summit before mr. Trump abruptly called
it off last week but after a long
meeting at the White House Friday with a
top North Korean official mr. Trump did
reverse course he also lowered
expectations for any quick deal Errol
Barnett is at the White House with the
latest
Erol good morning good morning North
Korea's former spy chief kim yeongcheol
was only supposed to deliver a letter
from kim jeong-hoon
to president trump on Friday but instead
the two appeared to hit it off meeting
for more than an hour and resulting in a
reversal the process will begin on June
12th in Singapore after meeting with kim
yeongcheol at the White House Friday
President Trump declared the summit
between North Korea and the US was on
again I think it's gonna be a process
but the relationships are building and
that's a very positive thing last week
mr. Trump called off the one-on-one in a
letter to kim jeong-hoon
citing tremendous anger and open
hostility expressed from the north as
reasons for calling off the summit kim
yeongcheol visited the White House to
officially deliver a response really
this was a letter presentation Trump
called the letter from Kim interesting
but then admitted he had not actually
read it before reestablishing the summit
yeah I purposely didn't open the letter
I haven't opened it North Korea and the
US had been at an impasse over
verifiable North Korean denuclearization
and the reversal of US sanctions on the
north the two nations have not agreed on
timing
president Trump voiced optimism about
denuclearization I know they want to do
that and said if North Korea followed
through the u.s. would work toward
lifting sanctions refusing to impose a
new set while talks are ongoing right so
what I look forward to the day when I
can take the sanctions off of North
Korea the president revealed they even
discussed an end to the Korean War can
you believe that we're talking about the
ending of the Korean War
you took it about 70 years defense
secretary Jim mattis in Singapore met
his South Korean counterpart and
reiterated at an Asia Security Summit
American priorities have not changed our
objective remains the complete
verifiable and irreversible nuclear e.e
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
maddis also said that the removal of US
troops from the Korean Peninsula was not
discussed and is not on the table for
the June 12th summit president Trump is
at Camp David this weekend where he is
preparing for that one-on-one meeting
and a very important detail here a
senior White House official says
President Trump did in fact read the
letter before he left for the weekend
Anthony okay that's good news Earl born
ed at the White House thanks